[Music]
you
y'all want to see their robot that's
supposed to be here we're kids man we'll
get away we say anything I was just a
normal kid for my world fell apart look
at me white candy until normal school
the normal life some kids tease me Wow
living as far as you're concerned my
boyfriend how long that's been doula
they say you run like a girl now we're
going to carry on promise don't expect
any spent on stories
you throw like a girl
[Music]
you had your mind you're not going
anywhere with me today and I want to
fight that think you're better huh it's
okay to be a kid little JLo funny what
you can do when all you have lasted pens
on you done fight like a girl
yeah I saw your girl coming with me or
what
thank you
you
[Music]
we go home
so why are you getting your mouth
[Music]
lots of losses right now come on then be
careful
you get back in your hole think about
what you did
you
you want to know why they keep coming
here where are the other ones you're
hiding I don't sell out friends
[Music]
you won't die
and then rhyme
[Music]
the secrets
my makers I do
[Music]
you